la indignación por el racismo en el
fútbol español ha llegado a nuevos
niveles con el presidente Brasil
condenando los continuos abusos a la
estrella del Real Madrid vinicios Junior
y el presidente de la federación
española de fútbol diciendo que España
tiene un grave problema
tenemos un problema en nuestro país
de comportamiento de educación de
racismo en un partido de visita un
aficionado del Valencia le habría
llamado mono al delantero brasileño el
juego se reanudó 10 minutos después de
un anuncio en el que se pedía que
cesaran los insultos racistas el Real
Madrid ha presentado una denuncia
judicial y vinicius ha emitido un
comunicado en el que afirma que un
campeonato que antes pertenecía a
grandes jugadores ahora pertenece a
racistas el presidente de la liga Javier
tebas respondió que vinicius tenía que
informarse bien quejándose de que el
futbolista no se había presentado a dos
reuniones sobre lo que están haciendo
para combatir el racismo pero el
entrenador del Real Madrid Carlo
ancelotti coincide con su jugador la
liga no está haciendo lo suficiente para
pensar de quitar un jugador para racismo
nunca me ha pasado la
liga española tiene un problema
que no es bien hechos problema bien
hechos es la víctima de un problema muy
grave la liga ha presentado denuncias
ante las autoridades españolas por el
constante abuso racial que sufre
vinicius Mientras tanto la policía
española Investiga un delito de odio
después de que aficionados del club
rival en el Atlético de Madrid colgarán
un muñeco de vinicius frente al campo de
entrenamiento del Real Madrid